Peter Browns here what up you've been
playing a video game for extended
periods of time in a gamespot office for
the past number of weeks the review is
finally out and for folks in North
America that can finally play what's the
game Xenoblade Chronicles X yes yeah or
cross I'll just see you bleed chronicles
cross yeah no blade Xenoblade Nathan how
you want eight out of 10 on gamespot com
tell us about it what's what's what's
one of what did you enjoy out of all of
the areas you play how many hours did
you play actually first of all 65 okay
and there is a lot more to see in the
game no I mean it is well from one it
takes place in a massive world that's
got about five continents that are like
we say the games are big these days this
is really really big like I could spend
hours on a single content and I remember
I'm only looking at twenty percent of
this game right now yeah but in that
space it also has a lot of quests and a
lot of opportunities to to earn new gear
make friends and ultimately you unlock
massive mex that transform into this
vehicle you see on screen right now and
I mean it is a huge game that is a
technical masterpiece especially on the
Wii U but even I think you know if you
look at other games and other consoles
it's impressive how this manages to have
such a big world let's talk about I
guess the earlier parts of the game
because from what I was talking to you
last week this very much seemed like the
mecca of something that you reached
after say 50 hours or 40 hours of the
game it's not quite that bad okay but
yeah your first 30 hours are spent on
foot as a human you know you are a or
girl and you team up with three other
soldiers oh and and you essentially
you're trying to explore this this
planet that you've crash-landed on if
you don't know it's out there and you're
trying to find a thing that will ensure
your survival and I'm doing so you
encounter gigantic monsters and and
things like that and it's really
wonderful like aa surprising experience
yeah it's got good I will get to him in
a second okay Elton John so I mean this
is really a game about exploration in
combat and it has many many layers of
systems and subsystems in it and
unfortunately
the start a lot of the like how those
things work together is pretty ambiguous
the game won't introduce a concept and
then just sort of leave you to go do
whatever you wanted to do without really
giving you many examples of how it works
now I'm not saying that it necessarily
needs a tutorial to explain everything
but I had to go to the in-game digital
manual to figure out a lot of stuff
right it's very difficult to to
understand intricacies of everything
involved in this is that the sort of
thing where if you'd played previous
games you might have a tighter handle on
or is that what maybe but I played a
hundred hours of Xenoblade Chronicles on
weed and even then I was lost because
there are so many things that are brand
new here so many little things that have
to do with gear and skills and sort of
managing your relationships to the
military that you're a part of and
working with the different divisions
inside of it I mean there's there's a
lot to juggle lots of different Quest is
that obviously the main cry stuff is all
this like affinity site character-based
quests as well yeah and this was
something that was a huge part of the
last game but so do you have main quests
you have side quests which are just
simple you walk up to someone to give
you a question but these affinity
missions as they're known are used to
sort of form a web of relationships and
how you manage those relationships can
influence how other missions open or how
certain people react in certain
situations I found because you have to
find someone in the right location at
the right time of day to even get the
mission right and then have all these
prerequisites and they tell you to go to
places that never heard of like there's
a big base you have to explore and you
know out of necessity you go to some
places curiosity will take you to other
places but if you're busy in the field
fighting because that's what you want to
do you're not going to know where to
find Derek in the commercial district at
noon I mean it it's sort of it leaves
that up so affinity missions are a good
idea that I think don't work as well as
they should right but yeah the side
quests tough and an exploration in
general and most of the story missions
are really good they encourage you to
explore the exploration is great what's
the combat like I know a lot of the game
is about exploration but ultimately it's
also about shooting stuff lots of crazy
Beast someone not on this world yeah i
mean this is this game captures what
it's like to be in a prehistoric
environment better than any game I've
played so yeah you control 80 Ryan Dino
beatdown
no I guess I don't want prepared to
speak about it yeah so a team of up to
four characters and you only control one
at a time it's a real-time combat system
you have one ranged one melee weapon and
you can choose from a few different
classes that specialize in different
types of offense and defense and you
know you don't have to play as the main
character the avatar you create you can
play the supporting characters as well
if you choose but you can only have one
at a time and you have to sort of
reorganize the party one problem i do
have with combat while it is really
exciting and can be really great healing
is something that is i think too complex
where in most RPGs you either have a
healer class or someone who can at least
use consumable items to heal you in this
game you rely on a system known as soul
voices so let's say my health drops
below twenty percent I can then set
something to happen when that condition
is met maybe it's healing maybe it's
something else so at that level that
makes sense but the game throws a quick
time event at you right in those
instances and you have to react very
quickly in most cases and healing isn't
always something that you have total
control of hmm which I don't really love
but um you know it sort of punishes you
at the most difficult parts of the game
well it's tough to say because there
were plenty of opportunities where I was
fine with it rarely i felt like man I
hope something happens that can heal me
you know it could have been in common
battle where I just slipped up it could
have been a big battle it didn't define
the combat experience but it was one of
those things where if I had my way I
would have used a potion and healed
myself immediately some of the best
stuff we're seeing here is with the or
most interesting footage wise is this
awesome mech transforming into I guess
what looks like a motorbike or why not
talk about that what this does that
change the game fundamentally very much
like diversity in terms of the types of
mex that you can get off ok so like I
was saying the game is gigantic think
bigger than any game you've played
before and you're a human right then all
of a sudden you are in a 40-foot robot
you know the the giant odd like dear
dinosaur that was towering above you you
now look in the eye I mean it changes
your relationship to space
and in that way time if the two are
relative as you're going about this
world and trying to find things discover
new places engage with enemies that
initially you looked at as nope I'll
never be able to fight that in my life
but wow it's crazy now you can say I'm
gonna go kill it and co 2 drops Wow and
that's great and you can have a team of
up to four mecs are pretty expensive in
the game you have a good way to earn
money by exploring and planting these
things that mine the earth and you can
set up that system it's really complex
and so you can afford more Skills as
they're called and scales scales scales
they were called dolls in Japan but I
guess I didn't translate from love well
you know who wants to sales I don't know
if I feel like if you're already deep in
the plains and a blade yeah who cares a
penny in for a pound yeah I mean mechs
are one of the few things that are just
amazing about this game and the gorgeous
for a wheat love think that's what I'm
saying yeah but like there's a certain
arts law which seems to lend itself on
with you and it's not this no but this
looks pretty great actually it's great
yeah and you know again getting your mex
so late you've become so comfortable in
your relationship is just being a small
person that when you get this it is just
like I'm in a whole new game like this
just feels all brand new and they ate
they have like 15 pieces of gear that
you could like you know upgrade change
mod at augments to it like all this
great stuff it's it's for someone who
loves details and tinkering mmm there's
no shortage of stuff to do a great
little surprise for the wii u the end of
2015 it seemed like a sort of a solid
start and medium and it seemed to be
floundering there for a while we've had
a couple of you know between my or
tennis and yeah meebo festival and maybe
yoshi as well it hasn't been super super
strong this is a nice kind of ending 2
2015 for the weakness and super mario
maker are the best things to come out of
nintendo in the past few months prior
awesome peter brian thank you so much
for coming on thank you so much for
playing see them played like you know
the thankless job of being reviews
editor for a big website and also trying
to like rango game of the year stuff and
then you have to collect 65 hours of
this game on top of dude it was a
privilege like xenoblade chronicles is
an amazing game that i hope people by we
used to play because i want to i want to
play the next Xenoblade but i also have
like 200 hours left to spin with this
game so yeah great well ok you go and do
that in a second and thanks so much for
coming on
let us know what you think the comments
below if you've been playing as in a
blade Chronicles X or cross whichever
way you want to Zeno Zeno I'm not here
to judge let us know she think of that
game are you finally gonna buy wii u hey
all you tens of millions do it you
already only other consoles anyway right
maybe not the xbox one do it